- Sally sells seashells by the seashore.
- [All] Sally sells
seashells by the seashore.
- Sally sells seashells by the seashore,
and Sally was a real person.
- [Narrator] This is Mary Anning.
She sold rare invertebrate fossils
by the seashore.
Born in 1799, Mary was
something exceptionally rare
for a woman at the time, (thunder)
possibly because as an infant,
she was struck by lightning.
No, she really was.
(jaunty music)
She was a paleontologist, a
fossil hunter if you will.
When she was 12, Mary dug
up a 200 million year old
marine reptile, the
ichthyosaurus skeleton.
Translation: she discovered
the first complete
fish-lizard, ever.
Throughout her life, she
discovered tons of fossils
and sold rare invertebrates here
by the seashore of
England's Jurassic Coast.
Unfortunately, Mary lived in a time
when men ruled the roost and many of them
routinely took credit for her findings.
But even though she might not have gotten
the kudos she deserved while alive,
she has gone down in history
as the greatest fossilist
the world ever knew.
She was even selected as one of the three
most important female
scientists in Britain
and inspired a tongue twister that's one
for the history books.
- Sally sells seashells by the seashore.
- [Narrator] No, weren't you listening?
Mary sold fossils by the seashore.
(jaunty music)